هذه البقعه من العالم تنفرد بسر من
الاسرار الطبيعيه التي لا يعرف بامرها
كثير من سكان كوكب الارض
انها ولايه شمال كردفان الواقعه في غرب
السودان التي تقع بدورها في الشرق
الافريقي
وتعتبر هذه الولايه وجاراتها دره التاج في
صناعه فريده من اهم واندر المجالات
الصناعيه على المستوى العالمي وهي صناعه
الصمغ كما انها جزء من حزام طبيعي يعرف
بحزام الصمغ العربي
لمعرفه قصه الصمغ هذه قررنا الانطلاق في
مهمه استكشافيه خاصه
متجهين صوب ولايه شمال كردفان التي تعد
معقل الصمغ العربي
الشجره الصمغه العربيه شجره محوريه
تتمحور حولها كل حياه المواطنين
ليس الصمغ العربي هو المنتج الوحيد من
الشجره ولكن الشجره هي في الكلور هي حياه
للناس
ولكن المنتج السحري
واحنا بنسميه منتج سحري
من فوائد معروفه للجميع
مواطينا هنا في شمال كردفان احنا لا نعرف
تاريخ لهذه الشجره شجره مما الناس يعني
وجدت وجدت هذه الشجره يعني
تجمع التقارير والدراسات العلميه
والتجاريه على مستوى العالم على ان
السودان يتمتع بامتياز فريد حين يتعلق
الامر بالصمغ العربي اذ يستاثر هذا البلد
بما يزيد على ثلثي الكميه المنتجه على
مستوى العالم فضلا عن استئثاره باجود
اصناف اشجار انتاج الصمغ كشجر الهشاب
والطلح وغيره